OCTOBER 23RD.
WE'LL SEE YOU TOMORROW NIGHT.
HAVE A GREAT NIGHT.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING,
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT"
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
FOR 10 MINUTES HILLARY CLINTON
APPEARED TO RETREAT INTO
CONCLUSION.
SHE WENT TO THE WOODS NEAR HER
HOME LOOKING A LITTLE LOST.
SOME PEOPLE MADE FUN OF HER FOR
DOING THAT, BUT IN FACT IT WAS A
PROMISING START.
HUMILIATION CAN BE THE BEGINNING
OF WISDOM FOR THOSE OF US THAT
HAVE BEEN FIRED IN PUBLIC.
THE PERIOD DIDN'T LAST LONG.
BEFORE LONG HILLARY WAS BACK ON
THE ROAD FOR YEARS, LIKE THE
CIRCUS.
SO MANY CITIES, SO MANY EXCUSES.
>> THE RUSSIANS, WIKILEAKS, SAME
THING, THEY DUMPED THE
JOHN PODESTA EMAILS.
I HAVE MY COMPLAINTS ABOUT THE
FORMER DIRECTOR.
THE USE OF MY EMAIL ACCOUNT WAS
TURNED INTO THE BIGGEST SCANDAL
SINCE LORD KNOWS WHEN.
THEY COVERED IT LIKE IT WAS
PEARL HARBOR.
IF YOU LOOK AT FACEBOOK, THE
VAST MAJORITY OF THE NEWS --
NEWS ITEMS POSTED WERE FAKE.
THERE'S ALL THE STORIES ABOUT
GUYS OVER IN MACEDONIA WHO ARE
RUNNING THESE FAKE NEW SITES.
I INHERIT NOTHING FROM THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
I ALSO THINK I WAS A VICTIM OF A
VERY BROAD ASSUMPTION I WAS
GOING TO WIN.
AT THE ELECTION BUT ON OCTOBER
OCTOBER 27TH I WOULD BE YOUR
PRESIDENT.
IT WAS ON OCTOBER 28TH AND THERE
WAS FUNNY BUSINESS GOING ON.
>> Tucker: THE RUSSIANS!
WIKILEAKS, THE MACEDONIANS!
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY ITSELF.
HILLARY CLINTON BLAMED THEM ALL.
THIS IS NOT SOMEBODY COMING TO
TERMS WITH A LOSS, IT WAS
SOMEBODY REFUSING TO ADMIT ONE.
IN FACT OVERTIME THAT BECAME HER
POSITION ON THE WHOLE THING.
DESPITE WHAT YOU MAY HAVE HEARD,
SHE DIDN'T REALLY LOSE THE 2016
ELECTION.
SHE WON IT, SHE'S THE REAL
PRESIDENT RIGHT NOW.
THIS IS A REELECTION CAMPAIGN.
AS RECENTLY AS A FEW MONTHS AGO,
DEMOCRATS WOULD'VE LAUGHED
PRIVATELY AT THAT IDEA.
NOT ANYMORE.
NOW SOME OF THEM ARE TAKING
HILLARY MORE SERIOUSLY THAN THEY
HAVE BEEN A LONG TIME.
AN ARTICLE IN YESTERDAY'S
"NEW YORK TIMES" DESCRIBES
GROWING PANIC, JOE BIDEN LOOKS
WEAK AND INCAPABLE.
MUCH OF THE FIELD CLEARLY IS TOO
EXTREME TO WIN A NATIONAL
ELECTION.
WHO WAS GOING TO BE DONALD TRUMP
NEXT YEAR?
SOME ARE STARTING TO THINK IT
COULD BE HILLARY CLINTON.
CLEARLY THIS IS A THOUGHT THAT'S
CROSSED HILLARY CLINTON'S MIND.
IN PRIVATE SHE HAS EXPRESSED HER
WILLINGNESS TO GO INTO THE RACE.
THEY JUST ADDED A POLICY SUCTION